the European Parliament is debating
developments in Israel and Palestine
this comes a day after confusion over
whether the EU would suspend Aid to
Palestinians or not the European
commission appeared to backpedal on its
earlier announcement that it would stop
payments this after several member
states protested well for more on this
let's go to Natasha Butler who's in
Paris Natasha what's what's the debate
going to be like at this uh European
foreign ministers
meeting
well look the EU is made up of 27 member
states and as you can imagine uh it's
very difficult to find consensus even if
that's what those member states uh aim
to do they're always going to be uh
divisions and what they're doing is
they're talking about uh European Union
uh Financial humanitarian Aid to the
Palestinian territories uh because on
Monday there was some confusion about
whether that Aid would continue a top
commissioner the EU said that that Aid
had been suspended very soon some member
states complained about that said you
can't take unilateral decisions in that
way so that's why foreign ministers
today are discussing and reviewing they
say uh the situation with the eu's uh
financial and humanitarian Aid to the
Palestinian territories now I think most
are agreed that humanitarian Aid will
continue but whether other types of Aid
will continue that remains to be seen so
things like for development or Aid that
goes to the in authority to pay uh civil
servants what some uh States and member
states are concerned about is that some
of that money is being indirectly going
to Hamas and they are worried that Hamas
has used that money uh in uh when it
carried out those attacks against Israel
so of course they want to make sure that
that's not what the case and they want
to prevent any future money if it's to
be sent doesn't fall into the wrong
hands right now as we speak is the aid
suspended or is the aid continuing are
they still sending uh money or whatever
form the aid was taking to the
Palestinian
[Applause]
Authority I think it's probably very
complex and we probably don't really
know but according to uh the EU foreign
policy Chief as far as we understand he
was saying that there were no uh
scheduled payments right now so I think
as we are now we're in a bit of a gap
anyway there weren't any payments
necessarily on its way as far as we know
though humanitarian Aid will continue
other sorts of Aid may be suspended in
the future or may not be countries like
Austria and Germany have suspended their
national uh Aid that they send to
Palestinian uh territories but we know
countries like France uh Spain Ireland
Luxembourg are very much saying whatever
happens the humanitarian situation must
be a priority and Palestinians must
receive Aid at such a difficult a time
but as I said look in the European Union
there are always divisions there's
consensus is very hard to find with so
many member states will have to see what
comes out of that meeting it's certainly
an opportunity for them to review the
situation all right Natasha Butler uh
thank you very much for that reporting
from Paris I want to get the perspective
of James Moran who's joining us from
Brussels now you're a former EU
ambassador to Egypt Jordan and Yemen so
it's so good to bring you back on the
show because you would have some you
know you were an Insider uh and you
would have great insights onto what
might be into what might be happening
now what do you think of the
conversation that's been taking place in
in full view of the public within EU
member states over the last 24 hours I
mean we had an EU commissioner or
spokesperson for an EU commissioner
saying we're stopping all the aid and
then several countries clearly in
disagreement major disagreement with
that and now they're saying actually for
the moment it's it's
continuing yeah it's really unfortunate
uh it's a lot of confusion at the moment
uh caused by the tragic events going on
on of course in Gaza and Israel right
now um and it doesn't um bode well for
the discussion that the ministers are
having right now in the margins of
meeting they're having in Oman the
European foreign ministers I think the
um the overwhelming argument against it
is going to be made certainly by many of
the member states against the suspension
or whatever of Aid is that by doing that
you are penalizing um many many
Palestinians who had nothing to do do
with the Hamas attacks and indeed you're
empowering Hamas which itself is going
to be able to say look here you see how
the West doesn't support us when we need
it uh and so on and so forth so I think
there's going to be a very very strong
push back about against any proposal at
EU level uh about the aid that is
provided through the European Union
budget uh we'll see what happens in the
meeting we should know in about an hour
or so but I think there are strong
arguments against it doesn't make any
sense if the EU countries don't want the
Aid to go to Hamas um now to be very
clear to our viewers the EU considers
Hamas a terrorist organization so they
were never sending Aid directly to them
but the the the concern in some parts of
the EU is that perhaps the aid that
they're sending to the Palestinian
Authority perhaps trickles down that
concern has been expressed do you think
that concern is
valid no I don't and I think that there
have been very strong safeguards in
place for many years now about how eua
is administered and um spent uh in uh
Palestine whether it be um in the West
Bank or whether it be in Gaza when it
comes to development Aid and so on there
are firewalls and any number of uh
restrictions on the uh uh dispersement
of that Aid uh and those are in place um
whether or not new restrictions are
required well we'll see but for the time
being I think it's um it's pretty clear
that uh the eua that is provided goes
Prim primarily through the Palestinian
Authority for the benefit of Palestinian
people in Palestine is this conversation
within the EU about Aid to the
Palestinians is that just perhaps the
tip of the iceberg that shows some
pretty deep divisions within the member
states just about their their political
stance on the Israel Gaza
War yeah it does to some extent reflect
that there are very there are different
positions I mean you've seen special
Austria Hungary um and one or two others
who have taken extremely strong
pro-israeli positions uh and have um you
been very one-sided in what they've had
to say there are others and I think they
are in the majority who would prefer to
continue the traditional evenhanded
approach that the EU has had over the
years and um I think they're going to
Prevail at this meeting even if you may
see an announcement about some review or
some reconsideration of the safeguards
that I mention that have been put in
place um but I suspect that they will
prevail to do otherwise will um
marginalize the EU and indeed the
Palestinian Authority to an extent where
any Prospect for future peace
negotiations uh is even uh even dimmer
than it is at the moment James Moran
former EU Ambassador thank you very much
for joining us on the show uh with that
very interesting perspective you were EU
ambassador to Egypt Jordan and
Yemen thank you